still a lot of questions tonight
surrounding a deadly crash involving an
out-of-state off-duty police officers in
las vegas who are on vacation the
accident happened friday morning on
spring mountain in decatur a new haven
police officer died and another who was
driving a rented rolls royce is charged
with his death joe mohler finding out
more about the vehicle involved he's
live where it happened tonight joe
police say 34 year old robert ferrero
was driving that rolls royce on spring
mountain here when he lost control you
can still see the damage from this crash
here on this curb and even the markings
from the investigation 35 year old
joshua castellano was ejected and died
tonight information on where the group
rented the car and why these exotic
luxury rentals have become a concern
here in the valley he did not only touch
the men and women of this police
department
but the community as well the new haven
police department is mourning the loss
of officer joshua costellano while a
fellow officer faces charges of dui and
reckless driving resulting in death
metro says robert ferraro was driving a
rolls royce similar to this one 8 news
now has learned that 400 thousand dollar
suv was being rented by all-star cars of
las vegas
our photojournalist was confronted when
we attempted to ask if they rented the
rolls royce another representative
confirmed they did and said the crash is
a tragedy we need to make sure that
we're doing something to protect both
the person renting the car and also the
people on the street county commissioner
michael naff plans to discuss exotic
rentals at tuesday's county commission
meeting we need to make sure that the
people who are operating who are doing
business in clark county are doing it
the right way he says crashes are
happening too often in june a person
driving a lamborghini was allegedly
going 141 miles per hour before crashing
into a moped now driving a lamborghini
is no easy feat it takes three five four
minutes to even get comfortable to find
your seat controls let alone know how to
operate the car houston crosstalk owns
royalty exotic cars he says renters need
to be educated and regulation needs to
improve there's no regulation going on
and who's insuring the cars correctly
who's renting them correctly you know do
they have their bonds do they have this
do they have that it takes a lot to
become a rental car company
and now back out here live ferraro is
expected back in court tomorrow
reporting live near decatur and spring
mountain joe mullen live local now